eric sadin philosophes et spécialistes
du numérique bonsoir eric sadin merci
d'être avec nous je le rappelle vous
êtes philosophe donc on va essayer
justement de voir comment vous percevez
d'un point de vue philosophique ce
tracking dont on parle beaucoup 1 dans
les pays comme la corée du sud alors
déjà ce que c'est une solution qui vous
paraît vous envisageable dans notre pays
avec les mentalités françaises alors des
mesures ont été mises en place dans
plusieurs pays asiatiques
nous savons selon des niveaux différents
de façon extrêmement sens demandé
l'assentiment des citoyens des
représentants en chine
c'était à l'oeuvre en corée de façon on
à dire un peu plus un peu plus souple le
tout cela est notamment dû à la
confucianisme le respect de l'ordre non
respect l'attrait dominance du groupe
sur les individus nous nous sommes en
europe et dans des démocraties enquête
immédiatement là le dessin de deux
tracés individuellement les personnes
nous extrait moi ce que je pense qu'il
faut voir cela
au delà des insectes que c'est un peu ça
sans déchaîner actuellement est en
partie à juste titre mais je pense qu'il
faut voir cela avec six constructions et
prudence c'est à dire on vous dit cirque
ont cessé et prudents alors déjà il y à
des mesures sanitaires
et quand on dit sanitaire le sécuritaire
est très proche qui sont en place depuis
plus de trois semaines maintenant qui
nous aurait dit il ya un mois que l'on
marchait dans la rue il faudrait une
attestation qui auraient des drones dans
les espaces publics pour vérifier si les
personnes respectent des consignes
depuis 20 ans une situation inédite qui
le mec qui nous place dans des des
cadres juridiques sociaux absolument
inédit et qui d'une certaine façon au
trail de court alors on y répond
bon si on s'y plie pour là pour la bonne
cause pour la santé collective et
individuelle
là nous parlons d'une sorte de mesures
supplémentaires dont il faut relever
qu'elle est a priori extrêmement
impressionnante
c'est à dire nous avons beaucoup parlé
de la surveillance numérique depuis les
événements de 2001 depuis les
révélations de snowdon il ya une
sensibilité très aigu sur la
surveillance musique parce que elle
supposerait qu'elle soit globale en
temps réel qu'à pénétrer nos
comportements sur l'unique et que tout
cela serait géré au sommet en
l'occurrence avec le parent est à nous
n'aurions pas exactement à faire en cela
si nous décidions s'il est assis avec
l'accord du parlement où certaines
mesures ne nécessitent pas l'accord du
parlement d'ailleurs mes nuits non pas
vers cela pour l'instant nous décidions
de mettre en place des mesures de
traçage numérique avec des applications
alors si vous voulez je vous explique en
quelques mots un choix pas nous pensons
aux squales l'irréflexion l'état
actuellement un entraîneur est pour ça
que je dis qu'il faut voir cela avec
circonspection et précision
j'entends je bois des gens dire nous
allons être surveillés par tous des
caméras partout bientôt cet été pour
aller à la plage la part de mon
autorisation
voilà de l'argent parce que
effectivement vous coupez mais justement
ce serait peut-être l'un des moyens de
sortir de ce confinement alors est-ce
que entre de liberté si j'ose dire
bafouée laquelle est la plus acceptable
pour les français c'est peut-être oui
alors déjà où on te remonte aussi
postuler que le fait d'être de ne pas
être contaminé de matinée à la santé de
tous et une liberté individuelle et
collective a aussi des gens que la firme
était totale mais il va bien falloir un
jour ou l'autre nous l'espérons tous le
plus rapidement possible sortir du
confinement et en est un et entamer des
phases dites de déconfinement alors ton
cela il ya plusieurs mesures qui sont
qu'à la réflexion actuellement
et qui doit tous nous savons qu'il ne
relèverait pas de mesure unique mais
plutôt une sorte de couteau suisse de
mesures d' état sérologique l'obligation
du mage du port du masque que le respect
des gestes barrières et notamment son
parc section on se parle du tout si ça
va être mise en place les mesures qui
viseraient à parce qu' il y ait une
traçabilité des contacts c'est à dire
par le bluetooth par la technologie
bluetooth enfin les smartphones que les
personnes que nous avons contacté avec
qui nous avait tant au contact d'agen à
peu près jusqu'à une distance maximale
de 2 mètres à peu près six lits à une
contamination qui est avérée dans un
second temps et bien les personnes qui
ont été en mise en contact soit un sort
lui ai alors voyez que pour l'instant le
projet s'il est mise en place
supposerait qui est le consentement
personnel alors voir le consentement
individus à leur rendez compte que si on
met cette mesure et qui va falloir
attendre l'accord du tout le monde ça
risque d'être une demi-mesure voir une
mesure à la marge
alors il y à des réflexions à mener
maintenant j'entends dire qu'il faut que
le principe de proportionnalité endroit
qui est d'essayer soit respectée certes
mais là c'est une proportionnalité
j'ai presque envie en proportion c'est à
dire de faire en sorte que la pandémie
ne ne redémarre pas donc je pense
si vous voulez un peu le bout de ce
premier moment de réflexion dont ont
fait part je pense qu'il faut que entre
les cas pour ce qui est de la france
qu'il y ait une sorte de pacte
m'explique c'est à dire il faudrait que
le gouvernement s'il juge le président
la halle public l'état et des autorités
de l'état s'il jusque ce sont des
mesures qui s'avère pertinente et bien
qu'il ya une sorte de pacte c'est à dire
durant un moment qui serait appelée à
être renouvelée selon des modalités
juridiques législatifs qui serait trouvé
et bien nous allons devoir mettre en
oeuvre certaines mesures qui
vivre est à les protéger et je le
rappelle c'est une liberté à des viols
celui d'être beau ne pas être convaincu
d'être en bonne santé alors seul un peu
la question de la chronologie d'un
troisième mouvement va être décisive
et pour cela il y a des organes de
vigilance en france nous sommes pas un
pays démuni dessin pays à la longue
tradition démocratique il y a deux
organes de vigilance il ya la cne merci
pas de crocs oui pardonnez moi je suis
obligé de vous couper donc dans cette
philosophie mais ce qu'on a on arrive à
la fin de notre émission n'a besoin que
quelqu'un le messager excusez-moi de
vous avoir coupé dans cette réflexion
merci eric sadin rappelle que vous êtes
philosophe spécialiste en tous les cas
il vient chantier qui appelle la
responsabilité collective et peut-être
de mettre certaines certains affecte les
médias de côté au profit de dinde un
calendrier rigoureux qui soient décidées
démocratiquement
on aura l'occasion certainement d'en
reparler avec vous merci à vous eric
sadin